blake shelton is giving gwen stefani son
kingston all the love on his 14th
birthday
as part of a birthday tribute to her
firstborn son when posted an adorable
Instagram video of her beau showering
Kingston with kisses and it looks like
he just loved it the hollaback girl
singer also shared a rare portrait of
the 14 year old who was all smiles on
the beach
rocking bleached blond hair with some
cool jewelry including a necklace with
his name on it there we say he's giving
us some jahnvi Outer Banks vibes I mean
he just looks so grown up
and Gwen praise Kingston in the caption
writing happy 14 fidei - my firstborn
son
thank you guys for making me his mama
hashtag love you Kingston James
Kingston's dad and Gwen's ex-husband
Gavin Rossdale also took to Instagram
Twitter son a happy birthday
posting a collection of photos with a
heartfelt caption reading King you blow
me away
such a kind funny smart handsome not a
spirited articulate dynamic sapien
you're so full of love and humor it
feels like we got something right
although the credit belongs to you and
he didn't stop there adding Kingston is
the love of his life now Gwen and Gavin
also share two other sons
eleven-year-old Zuma and six year old
Apollo the pair split back in 2015 and
shortly after when found love with Blake
Shelton now the couple often spend a lot
of time with twins three children and
made their first ever public appearance
as a fivesome at the ugly dolls movie
premiere in LA back in 2019